[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je vous rappelle que vous avez des
des tablettes tactiles pour les multis
chénier donc c'est très simple besoin
d'être proposition et vous tentez de
répondre correctement à la question très
bien qui si tout va bien c'est très
facile c'est très bien c'est très vite
d'abord celui qui a le moins de points
aura un gage un gage pendant la pub ce
sera un petit un psy facebook live avec
ses paroles je vais réfléchir j'ai
trouvé j'attends qu'on surtout qu'on me
le dise alors quelle est la
particularité de la femelle kangourou
elle ne porte jamais de slip elle peut
s'endormir de boala trois organes
génitaux
allez on répond et pourquoi ça s'allume
pas un malade sur les doigts edwards est
pas simple c'est très bien
alors est elle prête une question on a
dans drôlement bébé alors c'est là je
n'ai pas eu alors la bonne réponse je ne
savais pas c'est qu'elle a trois ans il
ya 3 me drapeau et benoît
rwasa non mais et nos gagnants et moi je
me suis vraiment un truc cet été sur les
combines gang mes vacances de merde vous
avez des enjeux en australie mais
pardonnez moi parce qu'un kangourou
aussi sans dormir debout
on n'est pas là non plus pour refaire
les questions suivantes pour l'instant
ça démarre ça démarre très mal surtout
vous allez voir pour leur part quand
vous savez que le bébé kangourou ou
gentil mais ne fait que 200 / c'est tout
petit elle le met dans la poche et puis
qu'on dit c'est comme exigence
alors quel animal peut se déplacer à
prêt à écouter bien à près de 300 km
heure est ce que c'est le faucon pèlerin
parce que c'est l'espadon ou est ce que
c'est la laurence ferrari drôle ça va
aller allez-y des mesures ou de répondre
la voie jeudi à venir alors allons-y
encore chanter la bonne réponse
la borrego c'est le repos a réponse à le
faucon pèlerin option il fait des
pointes vers les péchés bacchantes
ah ouais je me suis dit qu un espadon
finalement n'arrive pas vraiment à
mesure et l'espadon vouliez ses 100
kilomètres heure ah bah tant mieux
écouter on avait beau mais ça tombe bien
alors tu vas question suivante quel
animal est le mieux membrés au monde où
là c'est pas genre de questions qu'on
pose en moi même si on écoute et
messieurs est ce que c'est à la baleine
à bosse est ce que c'est
b le rhinocéros ou c'est le montiel à
moustache
[Rires]
allez-y alors la réponse est sur la
table est je vous rappelle et facile la
bonne réponse est oui la bonne réponse
c'est la baleine à bosse sexe assez
écouté bien avec un s'est fait
qu'améliorer basket jusqu'à 3 mètres de
long est le jour de la tempête géante
toujours vous en mettez une co juin la
tente érigée en possède une anomalie de
nature
quelle est elle elle peut pas rentrer sa
tête dans sa carapace va marcher
respirer en même temps elle a toujours
tort et la tortue le tortueux jeu les
fans de torture ou de chez vous et je
les paie t elle celle de vienne corriger
l'effet de serré alors allez-y d'abonder
on va dire ça mais je ne veux penser et
ben est bien la bonne réponse à l'eysée
ainsi chauffé bon françois hébel bande
annonce elle peut pas rentrer sa tête
dans ce cas on va faire un petit point
on va faire un petit point sur les
scores ouais ouais
alors non mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
remarquer me away en tête sabai est
troisième magali 3 maxime 3d le film
troie et il avait un bel 3 à l'attention
recettes de rue sur cette question et je
répète miss france n'ont rien fait de
jolis tu est très méchant ça c'est ça
c'est pas genre ça c'est pas gentil de
sa part et en plus ça que j'essaie
désespérément d'éviter ce qui me fait
bouffer c'est bon alors débat le diable
le diable de tasmanie est en marche
nuptiale carnivore qui a une
particularité commune
or aucun laquelle j'ai pas compris la
question là le diable diable de tasmanie
c'est quand le diable de tasmanie
amal al watani bord marsupial c'est
comme un kangourou lui est remise et un
point commun que les requins c'est
facile c'est damphousse toute sa vie il
peut sentir le russe en a des centaines
de mètres il a un aileron sur le dos non
aller
allez-y voir si certaines de ces
horribles aller eux bien j'en suis alors
j'ai aaa il n'y a qu'une seule bonne
réponse et c'est alex qui l'avaient aidé
en cause toute sa vie et oui moi je
pensais pas que c'était simple c'est
plein d'animaux dans les dents poussent
toutes les vagues bélair voudrais avec
le requin cherchez pas d'eau pas des
animaux
dernière question attention quelle
question que tout changer attention quel
animal n'a pas de cerveau est-ce que
c'est à l'étoile de mer est ce que c'est
mais le ver de terre ou est ce que c'est
c'est le de l'embout méchant c'est trop
facile
benjamin facile j'avais pas là je ne
réalise pas des questions je dirais
précisé à les réponses à ce truc là que
ça a marché vaudois qui marquera
effectué 11 à tout est défectueux je
crois à 13 ans déçus attention tu sais
pas si j'ai répondu à la baisse cette
façon il fait que sa tante louise harel
ça ne fonctionne pas pour les appels à
s'en séparer
on y va alors la mort répond c'est
l'étoile de mer les jeunes mères et week
alors du coup est du coup pour les
scores sa pelouse arrosée un nom alors
l'étoile de mer hélas ni tête ni cerveau
d'ailleurs pas ta 4 les scores on en lit
ou dans lé score 3 3 3 à alet-les-bains
banon et basset et basse sébacées
mosimann qui met on facebook
voilà